今天這個案例，說起來有點出乎意料，不是那種順風順水的成功，反而是在一個負面事件裡找到機會。
怎麼說？負面事件，大部分公司不是都想著怎麼止損嗎？
就是這樣。你想想看，如果今天你隔壁的國家突然關閉邊境，對做生意的人來說，是不是等於貿易路線斷了？
那當然啊，物流成本飆高，交貨延遲，甚至可能單子都沒了，這很頭痛。
對，大部分人會覺得這是個災難。但柬埔寨西哈努克港，就是一個深水港，它反而從泰國邊境關閉這件事裡找到商機，而且還賺錢了。
賺錢？等等，這有點說不過去吧？泰國邊境一關，理論上柬埔寨的貿易也會受影響才對。它怎麼會反而「受益」？
這就是有趣的地方。原文裡有提到，因為泰國邊境關閉，很多日本跨國企業原本要走陸路進泰國的貨，現在陸路不通了，它們得找新的運輸方案。
所以這些貨就轉到西哈努克港，然後再從海路運過去？
沒錯。西哈努克港變成了一個重要的替代選項，特別是對於那些貨物急著要到泰國市場的企業。
我猜啦，這個港口肯定收了很高的費用吧？不然怎麼會「賺錢」？這種時候，客戶沒得選，港口當然會拉高價格。
你說對了。原文有提到，這些貨物的高昂運費，已經讓一些日本公司公開呼籲港口應該降低費用了。這也側面說明了港口目前的收費確實不低。
這樣看來，這模式好像有點趁火打劫，不太道德，而且能不能持久也是個問題。疫情過後，邊境遲早會開放，那它的優勢不就沒了嗎？
嗯，這點我有考慮過。但換個角度想，對港口來說，它只是提供了在緊急狀況下的一個必要服務。而且，它能被選中，說明它本身就有深水港這種地理優勢。
地理優勢是基礎，但關鍵應該是它有沒有及時意識到這個轉變，然後把服務準備好。不然就算有港口，客戶也可能轉去別的地方。
確實。我想，西哈努克港當時的管理團隊，一定很快就意識到這個邊境關閉，會對原本的物流產生什麼影響。而且，他們肯定也評估過自己港口的能力，能不能承接這些額外的貨運量。
這對於我們一般中小企業來說，能學到什麼呢？難道也要等著鄰國出事嗎？
不是等著出事。而是像原文說的，面對「外部衝擊」時，你能不能換個角度去思考，有哪些潛在的機會。就像我們可能平常只專注在自己的「主線任務」。
你是說，像我們上班族，可能只看到自己手上的工作受限，但沒想到有沒有辦法繞個彎，或者從不同的角度去完成？
對啊。比如公司突然調整策略，你手上的專案可能被擱置。一般人會覺得糟了，是不是白忙一場。但有沒有可能，這個專案的某一部分，可以適用到新的策略上，或者幫助其他部門？
等等，這裡我有疑問。你這個例子，感覺是把「被動調整」當成「主動創新」，這兩者還是很不一樣。港口是「從無到有」抓到商機，但上班族是被迫調整。
其實這兩者有共通點。西哈努克港並非「創造」了商機，而是「發現」並「利用」了因外部變化而產生的新需求。對上班族來說，也是面對一個外部變化，你的職涯路線或工作方式是不是有新可能？
你的意思是，這種案例提醒我們，要更敏銳地觀察環境變化，然後評估自己的「資產」有哪些，能怎麼運用。
嗯。特別是那些看起來「被邊緣化」的資源，或是「不被看好」的選項，會不會在某個特殊時機，突然變成關鍵？
這個港口案例的啟發，好像也提醒了我們，有時候阻礙，也可能變成某種意想不到的契機。